[Music]
it's exclusive video that you saw first
right here on the long crime Network
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber we've got our hands on
hours of interrogation video that shows
officers questioning only fans model and
murder suspect Courtney clenny and it
actually catches the moment when the
cops reveal that her then boyfriend
Christian obamselli is dead
unfortunately the doctors did what they
could Christian is dead
oh my God
this is not real right okay
Christian died I I he I need to I need
to hug my mom
I cannot be left alone in like a room by
myself
no that's not true that's not that
didn't die that's not real right
Christian didn't Christian is dead yes
all right let's give you a quick time on
the case so both the prosecution and the
defense have conceded that clenny and
obamacelli had this volatile abusive
relationship and in April the two got
into a fight in their Miami Florida
Apartment things got physical and plenty
told police that she threw a knife at
obamselli in self-defense but according
to the medical examiner the knife went
into him near his shoulder hitting a
major artery and he bled out and died
clenny was detained in question but not
told that her boyfriend was actually
dead until near the end of the
interrogation police released her but
four months later in August she was
charged with murder now her defense team
argued that for Bond but the judge
determined that she could be a Flight
Risk because she reportedly made
millions of dollars through only fans
and during her four hour wait and
interrogation at the police station
officers asked Lenny to sign a form
waving Her Miranda rights if she had
asked for a lawyer the questions have to
stop but here's what happened she seems
to stop just short of specifically
requesting an attorney
but here's the thing because this is
constitutional rights labor my dad
handles my lawyer
I'm not going to take a court appointed
lawyer my dad handles my lawyer I would
not be calling my lawyer so my dad is
the first person to write a call
I think that makes sense
I've never been in a situation like this
where where somebody's Hospital
I've never been in this kind of
situation that's why like I don't want
to do anything wrong
you know
I mean it's it's your decision at the
end of the day
um but what happens if not
but not and that's it we don't talk
about what happened today
you just have to take uh
the stories that we've been told from
from the people next door and previous
situations
and try and narrow it down to what
happened today
all right let's get some expert Insight
right now with my co-host and public
defender Brian buckmeyer Brian there's a
good lesson here right what should
people do if they're ever in a situation
like this say I want a lawyer I do not
want to speak with you police will tell
you if you can't afford an attorney one
will be granted to you it's probably
something many people are familiar with
within the Miranda warnings is your
right to counsel at all parts of a
criminal case even the interrogation
it's protected under the Sixth Amendment
and like a lot of your rights it can be
waived but rarely should it ever be but
the question here is did Courtney
Clinton invoke her right to council
short answer probably not skoda says in
invoking the right to counsel must be
unambiguous and unequivocal you can ask
for a public defender or your own
attorney or just attorney in general
doesn't matter but saying I should call
my dad and he can call a lawyer may not
be unequivocal enough we spoke with a
retired NYPD officer about Miranda
rights and this is what he had to say
if somebody asks a question you know do
I need a lawyer that's not asking for a
lawyer in order for that really to kick
in now remember there's some
jurisdictions that are different so each
state has you know kind of uh you know
made their own rules or so but as
according to the Supreme Court the
person has to specifically say I want a
lawyer anything less than that it can is
considered not a request said that with
video confessions that convictions have
gone up and that has been good news for
the police I was a strong proponent of
this because I was going to you know you
get a chance to see what the tax were
used right so the defense attorney kind
of gets taken out of the subject because
the defense attorney would say well they
coerced my client they threatened them
they didn't do this but when that's all
on tape and they treated the person
properly and they gave them food and
they gave them ample rest and they gave
them bathroom breaks it's difficult to
say that the person was treated badly so
I I think going forward we will see the
video confession be used for not just
murder but just about every major felony
and they should be
yeah Jesse different states have
different standards five years ago in
Louisiana when a person said I want a
lawyer dog that wasn't unequivocal
enough because he could have been asking
for a dog like a canine that was an
actual lawyer
well that's hard to believe but I'm
pretty I mean look it's an important
lesson there Brian and thanks for that I
should tell you that while clayney
explained to the police what happened
inside that apartment previously
previously released video and text
messages show that prosecutors have
called a campaign of mental and physical
abuse against open selling in fact some
of the text messages reveal what could
be described as an increasing level of
violence with album Sully complaining at
different times of stabbing wounds to
his legs a concussion and cuts to his
cheek and Chin now I should also tell
you that the apartment building where
they were living was reportedly working
to have the two evicted because of
domestic disturbance complaints let me
bring in my co-host and former trial
Attorney Terry Austin into this
discussion so Terry it took four months
to file charges against clenny she was
actually a rehab in Hawaii they
extradited her back to Florida why this
delay you know four months it does seem
like a long time but during that period
investigators were actually gathering
information Clinic initially said she
was afraid that obamacelli was going to
hurt her again so she grabbed him knife
and threw it at him when he was about 10
feet away based on that information it
sounded like self-defense so the police
let her go but cliny's story did not
match information subsequently gathered
by the investigators the autopsy report
said the wound was a forceful downward
thrust so did she throw the knife or not
there's also evidence that cliny was the
primary aggressor in the relationship
finally the warrant said there was a
large amount of blood throughout the
apartment indicating that obamacelli was
bleeding for an extended period of time
so based on all that the authorities
finally charged her with murder yeah not
surprising considering all that Terry
thank you so much well police are
working a brutal quadruple murder case
in Idaho but they may be getting
sidetracked by online sleuths they're
now asking people not to contact the
owner of a Hyundai Elantra that many
believe could be connected to the case
take a look at these photos so a white
Hyundai Elantra was found abandoned with
no license plates in Oregon Moscow Idaho
Police were investigating whether it
could be connected to the November
stabbing deaths of four University of
Idaho students however police say they
have seen but they have been in touch
with the owner and she has no connection
to any property in Idaho Police believe
someone driving a white Hyundai Elantra
may have been in the area the night of
the murders and could have information
that could Crack the Case
over now to Texas where former Fort
Worth officer Aaron Dean learned his
punishment for shooting a woman while
doing a welfare check at her home Dean
stood trial for the 2019 death of a
Tatiana Jefferson after responding to a
neighbor's call about Jefferson's doors
being open late at night and that is
when Dean shot and killed Jefferson
through her bedroom window a jury
convicted dean of manslaughter last week
in that same jury was tasked with
handing down a sentence after hearing
more evidence following a day and a half
of deliberations they gave him nearly 12
years in prison Dean is eligible for
parole after serving half of his
sentence